let's go now to boulder mayor sam weaver
mayor weaver good morning to you
we watched live yesterday as the names
of the victims were read
publicly for the first time you spoke
and the city of boulder
began the process of grieving now 24
hours later
how's the city doing i think we're still
just getting out of shock
um you know it is is quite
difficult to digest um something like
this happening in your backyard
and so i think the grieving is just
beginning to
start as we learn the names and of
course the stories behind the people who
were killed
boulder is a city with a local ban or it
had a local ban on assault style rifles
like the one used in that supermarket
yesterday
not sure it would have made a whole lot
of difference though because statewide
they're still available
yesterday president biden called on a
federal national ban
on assault style rifles is that
something you think could have helped in
this case
i totally support that and i think it
could have helped absolutely
i mean one half of the problem that led
to
um the events of march 22nd
is that the availability of assault
style weapons is too high
the other half is of course identifying
and helping people with mental health
challenges but i think that
the weapon availability is what sets the
us apart from other countries
yeah the mental health challenges that
is a big component of this no doubt
about it
as far as that local ban goes a judge in
the state
overturned it said it wasn't
constitutional under state law
what are your next steps and what is
your message to your community this
morning about how you intend to
do your best to keep them safe so our
next step is to keep pushing on this
problem
from as many fronts as we can one of
those fronts is i think we're likely to
appeal the ruling
of that district court judge in colorado
to the colorado supreme court
basically the issue at hand is whether a
home rule city in colorado
can make a rule about assault weapons in
light of the state preemption the state
preemption tells us we cannot so
we'll push on that we're also pushing
our state legislators
to put an assault weapons ban in place
statewide which is like the federal one
that was in place in the 90s
yeah the uncomfortable fact about
shootings like the one we witnessed on
monday as a as a nation
is that they are public events they
create a public
terror in their aftermath people can't
go about their business
as you pointed out so eloquently tuesday
without thinking of it
is there a plan in the days and weeks
ahead for a kind of public memorial a
public grieving process
you know we'll begin tonight um with a
council meeting we call the special
counsel meeting for tonight in which we
will
hear some words from national experts on
getting through
situations like this i know that there's
at least one vigil planned for tomorrow
night as well the community can gather
and remember those
who are no longer with us all right
mayor sam weaver on this difficult
morning thank you very much for joining
us